so we're gonna run inside
i'm gonna heal
we're gonna run inside
and as soon as he's aggroed
we're gonna quit out so as soon as you
hear him you wanna quit it'll take you
right outside of the fog gate and we're
going to attempt this glitch i have
never tried this glitch
hopefully it works because this can give
us a lot of runes really fast if it
doesn't work we can just keep quitting
out until we get it to work
basically what happens in this glitch
is that you glitch into the staircase
basically
so we want to stand pretty much right in
the middle
and we want to kind of stutter walk
until we are immediately prompted
to enter the gate we want to be as far
back as possible
this keeps stutter stepping forward
this message is annoying but it i'll be
prompted regardless
okay that might have been a bit too far
but we're gonna try it
so we traverse the mist
walk in
we're not gonna move
i don't hear him this may have worked
and we're gonna jump to the left
and he should just not move man
that's not hard at all
great so you're gonna blood grease up
your weapon
and just r1 until he dies
so yeah i forgot to do that i need to
write that down you want to pop this
golden pickled foot
before you kill him
it gives you more runes
uh when you do kill him which is
importante i'm gonna double this up
thank you kyle
but we use the blood grease to apply a
bleed so this doesn't take forever
[Music]
and there it is boys
there it is baby how many runes is that
that is 64
000 runes
and we didn't have to do anything
awesome man